he is the head coach of the indianapolis
colts in the thick of the afc
south hunt in the hint uh i mean right
in the thick of the uh the wild card
race he is frank reich how are you frank
hey rich how you doing i am doing fine
but four things first things first i
i saw that video of you talking to your
was it your granddaughter about
teaching her the four points of pressure
to hold the football i saw that video
that
made it i was beautiful man i mean i i i
you of course you're welcome i mean how
how do you find time
to be coaching a grandfather you know
that was actually after
i was actually after a game where the
family was in and we were all sitting
around on a sunday
sunday uh late afternoon early evening
you know watching football so
having a good time as a family that's
great so okay let's get into this here
um you're i'll just point point blank
i know you got to play him when you play
him and you got to take it when you take
it and i know you can only control what
you can control i gave you all the
coaching cliches trying to make sure you
don't give me one right now but
when you watch a monday night game like
last night do you hope that this dealers
win
so you don't get them three straight
losses and hungry and really angry
does that actually play into any thought
process for you
frankie yeah yeah the the human side of
you thinks all those thoughts
right and but then but what's happened
is rich when you've been around the game
as long as we have been around the games
you realize that you realize that those
are things out of your control and so
while
those thoughts go through your mind you
you've seen every scenario happen
already where good and bad so what you
know matters is how you prepare
to get back to the coaching cliches so
coming back to how you
yes get back to how you prepare and and
what we do
it's really about what we do and um so
that is your focus
well in terms of the what we do frank
you know obviously
you just mentioned how you're watching
football after a game that you're
playing with your family
um is it helpful that you there's a
monday night football game with
22 high-definition cameras and that that
you get to watch your opponent
did you pick up something last night for
instance well
yeah we we watch and of course this year
with all the audio and you know you're
listening to things and about that
you know sometimes you pick some stuff
up but for the most part
um for the most part you're just looking
at personnel
you know hey you're getting really
familiar with their personnel and what
they do
and um we've already washed a bunch of
tape on them so
uh it just kind of confirms some things
that you were thinking okay
so um when you're saying the audio
because again there's no
there's there were some fans in
cincinnati yesterday i mean uh
have you how do you combat that knowing
that that everybody is picking stuff up
um and how do you game plan for
something like that
this year yeah you play you play you
play along with the game
and you know we got a we got a really
experienced
quarterback who knows how to play that
game and um
you know so you know when we're making
all the checks and all the things that
we say at the line of scrimmage
you know we're we're throwing out just
enough
false information to keep people on
their toes i love
it that's great so you you just
philip is peppering stuff out there you
know just in case
there are ears listening yeah without a
doubt
yeah i mean you have to i mean that's
part of the gamesmanship of it i mean
those are some of the stories that you
talk about 10 years from now i mean
um so yeah and you you can't oh
obsessively you can't obsess about that
stuff but
you you pick your spots you know you
pick your spots
and and you throw out false information
and uh
you know just like you said keep them on
their toes well frank wright here on the
rich eisen show
you you know you've been around this
sport a very long time you've been
around veterans you've been around
uh young quarterbacks you've coached
them both
um phillip rivers did you learn anything
about him that you didn't know
have you picked anything up about philip
that you did not know
over these first 15 weeks of coaching
him
frank i mean yeah just getting a chair
his chance to coach him for three years
in san diego
right you know what we were getting knew
what we were getting here this guy's
just an elite
quarterback in this league and he can do
everything um
he can make all the throws he's a coach
on the field he's a great leader in the
locker room and on the field
he's just a great competitor still has
you know the question is physically at
39
can he still do it and the answer is yes
and he's proving that
well what about that foot what that
everybody's talking about
i know you don't probably like talking
about injuries it's getting better i
mean it was pretty bad
you know the first week that he played
on it it was still pretty bad but
it's getting progressively better is he
100 yet probably not but it's gotten
better each week
frank reich here on the rich eisen show
and what about this young running back
that you
you appear to be saddling up a little
bit more in jonathan taylor
uh walk me through his progression this
year yeah he's just
he's a special kid man i mean anybody
that you just talked to this guy for
five minutes and you're like saying
is this guy for real um he's just a
great teammate
great human being great competitor um
accountable just hard worker learner
and then he's just super uber talented
he's big strong and fast
and and smart so he's just gotten better
and better as the year goes on and um
so yeah we're starting to feed him a
little bit more but you know if you
watch our offense long enough you know
that
yeah he's going to get his touches but
nahim hines is a really good back
right jordan wilkins you know coming off
the bench we got a lot of confidence in
him and
you know we like to spread it around and
obviously ty hilton appears to be coming
on strong
there seems to be some sort of
connection with him in particular
obviously there's so many other
receivers that you have with philip that
the two of them are
sort of on the same page is that an
accurate assessment
for you yeah no doubt and and it is you
know he had a couple games early on
where
um he could have had some breakout games
we we had a couple
uh freaky things happen where you know
penalties that were called
you know he's got a big catch and he
gets called back and
you know so a couple games it might have
been close to 100 yard games but
so that really the big bigger production
hasn't come until
in recent weeks but um man he's
you know he's late it's late in the year
and he feels like he's running faster
than he's run all year
um he still is an instinctive route
runner he makes a big time
clutch play obviously in the game you
know on second and 20
you know down the middle in a
game-winning drive so um
and he's a great leader and he's just
one of the best leaders and teammates
i've ever been around so i mean it seems
like uh
things are obviously trending upward
things are
i'm wondering what it feels like for you
you've been around championship teams
you've been on them you've coached them
okay i mean
what what does it feel like with you
right here i know you don't want to
also state um something that could be
bulletin
board material but what does it feel
like to you
with this team in its current standing
with two weeks to go here
and championship hopes yeah yeah that's
easy i mean we haven't done we haven't
we haven't accomplished anything yet i
mean we get we put ourselves in because
i should say it this way we put
ourselves in good position to play
meaningful games we're still playing
meaningful games we're not in anything
yet we got to play well this week
so what you do is you keep a healthy
tension what it feels like to me
to answer your questions specifically
what it feels like to me is it feels
like a healthy tension
it feels like we're in a locker room of
guys who really believe we're good
but it also feels to me like we're in a
locker room where guys feel like we got
to work our butts off every week because
you got to prove it every single day
you're out on the practice field that's
that's that's what it feels like when
you're on a good team
certainly since it feels like a
double-digit win team's gonna be left at
home
uh in an eight seat outside looking in
even in an expanded place
yeah there's no doubt it's gonna happen
um so
that's why you know we gotta we gotta
keep pressing i mean there's nothing
given to us we can't take anything for
granted
we have you know an opportunity this
sunday that's against a really good
football team
and you know we gotta we gotta play our
best game of the year well and again if
you'll indulge me in the couple minutes
we have left here
uh frank reich of the indianapolis colts
here on the rich eisen show stepping
outside of your team
if you don't mind uh a quarterback you
used to be a coach for
um in carson wentz is uh out of the
starting position as we know
in philadelphia and a lot of people are
questioning whether he can be a starter
in this league again i'm wondering what
your thoughts on that subject
might be well you know chris you know
right now honestly i'm really just
focused on the guys
it's a fair question but i'm more
focused on the quarterbacks on our
roster
you know i know and love carson a close
friend of mine
and i think he's a really good player uh
you know have a lot of belief and
confidence in him personally
um but right now i'm just more focused
on our guys okay and then uh also
uh i i don't know if you saw this scene
that sean mcdermott and the
the bills returned to uh after clinching
the afc
east for the first time since 1995 the
year after you left there
after being there since the 80s with all
the fans showing up i wonder what your
thoughts were
when you saw this scene if you hadn't
we're showing it right now
frank i had great thoughts i had great
thoughts and i'm very happy to see that
you know i got a ton of respect for sean
mcdermott in the job he's doing with the
bills
and you know even though they're an afc
team yeah um
i i still have close ties to buffalo and
i still root for the bills i'm very
happy for their success and coach
mcdermott's success and
and for the people and for the fans of
western new york you know i mean it's a
it's a good group of fans and so uh i
did see i did see that highlight
and it did bring back good memories of a
good sports
of a great sports city though what when
was the last time you spoke to jim kelly
how he's doing frank he's when was the
last time
via during the season it's just text
every couple weeks
um but doing great you know um he's
incredible obviously we're very close
and just
a lot a lot a lot of love and support
going two ways here you know
um just one of the all-time great
teammates and friends i've had in this
business
and then uh last one for you too i'm
sure you looked over a line of scrimmage
and saw kevin green on the other side
in your day uh wonder what your thoughts
on his passing and just recalling his
his prowess on the field frank yeah i'm
glad you asked because we were talking
about it this morning a group of us
coaches
and just ultimate respect and love for
kevin
i mean we weren't close personal friends
never played with him or coached with
him but
played and coached against him many
times had many conversations on the
field and
this this guy's just a class act and the
way he played
the way he coached um his he had this
he had this way about in this positivity
about him this energy about him that was
infectious
and um and just very very sad to hear of
his passing
it is and it just makes you think again
you just got to have those moments and
enjoyment you have which is exactly what
i thought when i saw you with your
granddaughter and again uh
is she coachable though not to get too
personal did she still got some work to
do okay i've still got some work
on the security okay yeah it did look
like she was holding it high and tight
though
frank looked like she had that thing she
was
she was i was proud of her and i'm
assuming there are siblings and other
kids or cousins in the house that can
try and try and
bat the ball away so she's got to get
this thing straightened out i imagine
you know
no doubt it's a competitive and it's a
competitive household
coach thanks for the time uh good luck
down the road and uh let's let's connect
again happy holidays to you and yours
merry christmas
same do you register thank you that's
frank reich indianapolis colts
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here